when Joe Biden is not incoherently
babbling about illegal immigration he's
incoherently babbling about the supposed
pay Gap now the pay Gap is one of the
most overwrought ridiculous things in
American public life the notion that
women are being paid less for the same
exact work is not backed by statistical
evidence the reality is the play Gap is
almost entirely a creation of
differentials in work hours in jobs
chosen it is a differential in time
taken off from the workforce women tend
to take more time out of the workforce
because they want to be home with the
kids in many cases the basic idea that a
woman Works an hour a man Works in our
exact same job exact same credentials
since the woman gets paid less is just
silly it it actually is not true it's
been widely debunked Christina how
Summers has done that work many many
times before in fact in America's
largest cities it's been true for years
that people who are fresh out of college
without having taken time out of the
workforce women in the same Industries
tend to be paid as highly or more than
men that according to Time magazine that
goes back a full decade doesn't matter
we're still going to keep promoting the
quote unquote equity-based idea that if
women on average are paid less than men
or all of those extraneous factors for
all those confounds well you know that's
still not good enough we have to
equalize pay between men and women
pretend that women aren't not getting
paid enough for the same exact work as a
man so Biden's Administration earlier
this week tried out Megan Rapinoe who's
the least victimized victim in American
public life Megan Rapinoe is an
extraordinarily famous gay woman who has
not so far as I'm aware been victimized
in any of her media coverage she grew up
extremely privileged she she did not
grow up impoverished she has faced from
what I can see very little in the way of
actual life obstacles to success she is
now treated as a paragon of feminist
virtue she's a hero even though the
claims that she makes her talking about
her running for repeatedly who's she
married to isn't she married to some
famous person or something um she's
married to a woman I'm not sure who it
is I think it's another famous soccer
player if I'm not mistaken I don't
really oh oh Sue bird the WNBA player
okay like this one it was Megan rapping
on complaining she's not hate the same
as the men yeah you're not paid the same
as the men lady because you're in
women's soccer which makes money once
every four years whereas men's soccer
makes money pretty much all the time and
the men's World Cup is a multiple like a
large multiple bigger than the Women's
World Cup and you guys signed a contract
so if you don't like your contract you
could have not signed that contract but
here's Megan rapino come complaining
that she doesn't make sure he's going to
get into this but they actually make a
greater percentage of sales and they
have greater a greater bonus bonus
structure than the men in soccer in
professional soccer except the money's
just not there you're making millions of
dollars if she put that energy into
promoting the sport and really getting
out there and going out and making
people interested in women's soccer and
getting more girls into it and really
just being a positive force for her
sport what she could watch or for
women's sports in general what she could
accomplish but she's just out there
going bad bad complaint complain
complaint he's a World Cup championships
and four Olympic gold medals for the
United States and all I get to do is
speak and despite those wins at the
White House I've been devalued I've been
disrespected oh my God disrespected no
don't tell me you got a hate comment on
YouTube no dismissed because I am a
woman and I've been told that I don't
deserve any more than less because I am
a woman you see despite all
I've been told this because I'm a woman
I've been told that because I'm a woman
because I'm a woman men who do the same
job that I do they don't do the same job
that you do they don't you know how I
know because Megan rappino anytime you
want you can go play on the men's team
you can try after all gender is so it's
a social construct we've been informed
by the left that gender does not exist
it's completely a social construct so
since gender is a social construct
anytime Megan rappana wants she can go
try and play with the men that is not
gonna go great for making a raptor she
is not doing the same work that a man is
doing this is like saying that a woman
lifting weights like her job is to lift
weights she's doing exactly the same job
as a man when she wins a gold medal in a
weightlifting competition well not
really considering the man is probably
listening twice lifting twice as much
weight as the woman I mean not to put
too fine a point on this but in a
scrimmage the Women's World Cup soccer
team the gold medal winning Women's
World Cup soccer team lost to the under
15 football club from Dallas Boys
football club from Dallas the under 15s
a bunch of 14 year old like yes it was a
scrimmage but also so like you lost a
bunch of 14 year old boys no it's not no
that's embarrassing actually you're not
doing the same work it's like not and
it's embarrassing if you go on talking
all this [ __ ] and then you lose but
realistically it's not like you're going
against boys it's all absurd yeah okay
turn this around and say do you see what
I mean they're they're [ __ ] on me
just because I'm a woman I am being
debased and devalued because what about
when everyone tells me that my opinion
doesn't matter because I'm a white male
and I'm automatically a shittier person
that's so stupid shut up white guy
nobody wants to hear what you have to
say you're a white male it hurt
proclaiming she's speaking from the
podium of the Damned White House she's
been on every major television show
complaining about her fate she signed
voluntarily a contract as to her pay and
the Women's World Cup again is a
fraction the size of the men's World Cup
it's amazing but don't worry Joe Biden
assures us that there's not a single
thing a man can do a woman can't do
better not a single thing men can't pee
their name in the snow better man can't
open pickle jars better men can't pick
up heavyweights better men can't throw
off a baseball harder on average nope it
turns out every single thing a man can
do a woman can do just as well or better
which is why he should probably resign
and let Kamala Harris be president I've
told my daughter oh no granddaughters
from the time they would all not to
understand what I was saying
and I mean it
there's not a single thing a man can do
that a woman can't do as well or better
not a single thing give not a single
thing anything really there are things
that women can do better than men there
are things men can do better than women
but frankly I'm shocked that he still
thinks the distinction exists he can't
even Define what a woman is it turns out
that many men are better at being women
than women according to Joe Biden the
White House released this asinine
asinine Instagram picture the other day
that it's equal payday did you know
white men make the whole dollar Asian
women make 87 cents white women make 79
cents black women make 63 cents American
Indian Alaska native women make 60 cents
Hispanic or Latino women make 55 cents
okay so I have some questions I have
some this is what they'd show us in
school and then they tell us this is
like literally what they teach us in
school that show us how I'm so much more
privileged as a white man than
automatically going out in the world I'm
just gonna make more money because I'm
white according to this I should be mad
at all the Asian ladies too you know
it's all just anyone above you flip out
yeah just freak out major questions
first of all you're taking into account
no compound threat number of hours in
the workforce the amount of time taken
out of the workforce what kind of job
you have and none of that is taken into
account second you notice that it starts
with a white man make the whole dollar
how about Asian men how do they do in
the United States how about like
nigerian-born American immigrants they
do really really well in the United
States as it turns out so why are white
men at the top oh because white men are
always evil that's why when you just put
white men at the top that means
everything that follows is going to be
how crappy America is also are we to
believe I mean according to the left
this this violates the intersectional
hierarchy the only reason for this would
be discrimination of course right
intersectional concerns your membership
in various identity groups that decides
just how bad America is to you so
according to this chart the one that the
White House just put out in order of
people who are discriminated against it
goes like least discriminated against
Asian-American women then white women
apparently white women are more
discriminated against than Asian
American women kind of incredible
wouldn't have predicted that also it
turns out that black women are less
discriminated against than Hispanic or
Latino women because black women make 63
cents while Hispanic or Latino women
make 55 cents so apparently America is
super duper super racist against
Hispanic and Latino women but only like
a little bit less racist against black
women okay all of this is just crap it's
just crap it does not bear statistical
relation to reality it's just men have
different jobs than women men tend to go
into stem Fields women tend not to go
into stems so that is not due to
systemic this brings up the point of
what is behind that data and how did
they come to it so his argument is also
making assumptions that they didn't have
proper analysis which is probably true
because a lot of things that I do know
about the dividend Administration puts
out really shows a complete lack of
context and a complete lack of
intelligence all of the big tech
companies have been trying to recruit
women into these fields for a very long
time Lauren Summers the former treasury
secretary under Bill Clinton got himself
in hot water by pointing out that women
have different preferences in job
selection than men do this happens to be
accurate he also pointed out that if you
look at test performance when it comes
to math and science what you tend to see
is that the average is for men and women
tend to be pretty similar but that at
the tail end of the spectrum the curves
are different that male curve in terms
of test scores on math and science tends
to show a lot of really dumb men and a
lot of really smart men and the average
somewhere in the middle and for women a
lot of people in the middle very few
very dumb and very few very great at
Science and Tech hey that does not mean
that if you just pick a woman that she's
going to be worse off than a man it
means that when you're looking at a
statistical average of wages you have to
look at factors like this again women
tend to enter the stem Fields less often
than men and actually when you look at
countries that have supposedly
when you see stem field less often than
men that's a big part that I was just
talking about that earlier that as
Generations go on there will be more and
more and more women in the stem Fields
yeah if if this push to get women in the
stem Fields succeeds builds there even
less often than in countries where there
is more gender inequality why because if
a woman has to get a high earning job in
order to support her family it turns out
that she will pick a stem field because
that's where the money is but if you are
in the Netherlands where women don't
have to get a stem job in order to have
a decent way of life well then they
won't become doctors as often as they
will go into other forms of of job and
occupation University of Chicago
Economist Stephen Levitz has quote
rather than interpreting women's lower
wages of failure perhaps it should be
seen as a sign that a higher wage simply
isn't as meaningful and incentive for
women as it is for men how dare we how
dare we know every in every inequality
of outcome means that America is
terrible and horrible and no good and
very bad which again is why Joe Biden
needs to immediately resign and hand
over his seat to the incredible historic
black woman who is his vice president
that will solve all of our problems even
though by the way again they can't even
Define man and woman if you ask them
what is a man and what is a woman they
literally have no definition of these
things the easiest way to solve the
gender gap is to Simply have people stop
identifying as a member of gender at all
because gender is irrelevant boom no
genders no pay Gap incredible we solved
it guys it was that easy I wonder if I
ever get the chance to just stick up
Mike and Joe Biden's face what is a
woman what do you think he would say
someone who identifies as a woman he
can't oh you can't press the mic in his
face he's not even the Press isn't even
allowed to ask him direct questions
because the man is completely yeah he's
out of it it's a senile and brainless
it's really sad and it's cruel
[Music]
home oh my God there's a big [ __ ]
crack in the first shot I'd rather
riding on the wall won't last long